Seana starts us off this hour in Austin
Texas
hey Shana how are you hey I'm good um
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
okay
um right now I'm riddled with a lot of
guilt on some former spending habits and
I need to give you a little background
and hopefully you can point me in the
right direction but a couple years ago
went through a divorce I got the house
and I couldn't afford it so I was going
to sell it I moved out into a cheaper
place and a week later the place that I
moved into burned down so I had to move
back into the house I couldn't afford so
I had to use a lot of my insurance money
to make ends meet but I also mismanaged
it and spent it on things that I could
have done without I did replace a lot of
things but you know I did a little bit
of trouble and I just I feel I'm feeling
really guilty now because now that was
three years ago and Here I am looking at
once I sat down and have penned out my
budget and my debt I could have almost
paid off everything but the house and so
now I'm I'm riddled with that guilt and
I'm also worried that I'm not going to
be able I have another settlement coming
soon I hope that is going to help me put
a dent in my debt but I'm really afraid
that I'm gonna mismanage what I have
coming to me oh do you do you feel like
you've learned your lesson so much the
point where I'm physically sick about it
then why would you feel like you're
going to mismanage the next step because
I've sounds to me like you learned your
lesson as you why would you think you're
going to mess up again if history
repeats itself I know I don't want to
know right why would you I mean are you
that out-of-control personally why don't
you consider have one conversation with
me about how bad you feel about
overspending and then think you're going
to go do it again that's inconsistent
isn't it that I think and now that you
say that yes I did I don't think you're
gonna do it again I think you've had
enough I have had enough I'm just
listening to you after 20 years of
coaching people
I think you've had enough I think you
had your spree and you look back on it
and regret tastes bad and you don't want
to have that dessert ever again that's
the truth
yeah and that's that's good news that's
good news
see there's a difference between
conviction and condemnation let's take
away the word guilt a minute replace it
okay okay condemnation is riddled with
guilt and says I'm a failure because I
failed once and I will always be a
failure you've got a little of that
going on but I think you've got more
conviction going on and conviction says
hey I drove my car in a ditch and I'm
not gonna drive like that anymore
because I don't like my car in a ditch
okay that's me that's called learning
from experience and that's what a wise
person does I mean we've all done stupid
stuff anybody says they hadn't done
something stupid did something stupid
when they said that cuz we've all done
stupid stuff right well but how do I
look forward because all I can do is sit
here and say I had that cash in my hand
it's gone I don't have it anymore it's
gone it's gone it you know what that is
that's tuition to the school of life you
paid tuition you've taken that class you
don't have to take it again you've
already passed it okay so wait let me
give an example okay by the time I was
26 years old I had four million dollars
for the real estate three million
dollars for the dead a million dollar
net worth I was making $250,000 a year
starting from nothing I was so stupid I
lost every bit of that because of that
every bit of it and just about lost my
marriage Sharon just about she thought
she married Sir Galahad turns out she
married doofus you know and so she was
going to leave and she just didn't have
the money you know and so that that's
where I was now I got two choices coming
out of that I can condemn myself and go
well that's that's the definition I am
the guy that filed bankruptcy that
defines my life or I can get conviction
which goes Cod stupid stuff hurts I'm
not doing that stupid stuff anymore hmm
and I changed my direction 22 or 25
years ago whatever it is now and
change the direction said okay what dumb
things that I do that I'm never going to
do again see what you need to do is you
need to write down your three never
again
there's at least three never again Xin
your story okay one is when I'm hurting
emotionally I'm not going to make big
financial decisions and medicate my pain
with spending okay because you did that
right
I read that into your story when my
wrong you are absolutely right I said I
bought myself out of pain yeah yeah you
did retail therapy or whatever you want
to call it and that's that's not that
unusual so it doesn't make you really a
bad person but you just need to write
that down and go next time I'm in pain I
put the checkbook up I'm not that's not
going to do Alma deal with pain never
again am I going to do that there's
first never again second never again is
I'm going to make major decisions like
housing very slowly not on impulse and
on emotion okay as you met you told me
three house choices all three of them
were kind of bad now one of them was
good but two of them were bad come to
think of it moving out and selling was a
good idea house burned down that you
know that I won some heated Rome but
moving back in was a bad idea
well that only had to move back in
because 1600 homes in the area burned
down as well and whoa had a vacant house
okay yeah well that we have a choice
okay
it was IRA try I retract that one people
watch what you do is you do an autopsy
on the only series of events and you
extract from them principles that you
apply to your life from now on how old
are you 38 you remember your grandpa or
grandma talking about the Great
Depression
were they old enough um I do remember my
grandmother talking about it you know
she was changed forever by that
experience right I think so yes yeah
you're changed forever by your
experience it was a good thing it made
her more frugal and thoughtful about
money because she was a child of the
Great Depression you're going to be more
frugal and thoughtful about money
because you went through a fire and a
divorce and you did some stupid stuff in
the middle of it that you're never going
to do again you're awesome I think
you're gonna do great where do I go from
here I'm I'm afraid that I'm afraid to
spend money that I have now now I'm
gripped in fear to spend the money that
I have set aside pay my bills that's
what I mean you're not you're not gonna
not you're gonna keep your lights on
right no of course not about so money
right yes okay so I don't mind you being
afraid about other stuff slow down it's
going to take you a little while to heal
from this and make decisions with money
on purchases nonsurvival purchases
you're gonna always be a little tinder
about theirs you made bad ones it's okay
okay you're doing good I'm telling you
listening to you I think you're gonna do
fine I really do
and I'm gonna help you I want you to go
through my not only class Financial
Peace University I'm gonna pay for it
okay oh my gosh thank you oh when you
learn how to handle money - if I do that
I not only will I learn how to handle it
I'll learn how to use it and better my
family and there you go and give it to
give the class to somebody else someday
when you're doing really good but you
just need some confidence again in
yourself and I'm telling you I think I
don't think you're gonna go back I don't
think you ever go back I think you were
changed by this negative experience in a
positive way this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you